[Music]
hey rob uh dan bridges here from
savellio missouri
and uh just so you know celebrating uh
12 years of continuous variety today so
i wanted to uh
to call your low down line and ask you a
question
in around 1996 or 1997
i was a part of the marine detachment
aboard as a aircraft carrier uss
constellation
and i distinctly remember coming aboard
and
i had a probably a short three-minute
interaction with you
and not that i expect you to remember
that but i wonder if you remember coming
on board and touring the aircraft
carrier and
if you were doing that as part of
preparation for a role or
kind of what the back story was behind
that
i've been able to find uh information
about you touring other ships
online but not the uss constellations
all right hope to hear back from you wow
i remember my time on the connie
i remember the connie
um and it's funny congratulations on
your sobriety because it's funny what i
was doing there was i was with a group
of people who were all in recovery
and we actually led
a meeting
on the boat
um so isn't it funny that you would now
be in recovery yourself
um
and uh gosh the first time you land i
flew out on the cod
you know and uh you know did the tail
hook landing and the
you know got the catapult off it was
i'll never forget it um
and then yes i then i got to spend some
time in the abraham lincoln
um when it was in santa barbara but i'm
a big
supporter of our military and i do a lot
of work um
usually around recovery i do a lot of
work with seals down in coronado and
also a lot of uh with their mental
health programs and um
in in my uh
my men's skin care line profile
our prophets some of our prophets go to
uh wounded warrior so um that's a big
part of
of my
charitable work on the side but um yeah
what a great memory i remember it well
oh my gosh you kidding me smoking cigars
with the bro with the bros blow decks on
the connie let's go
so good
um anyway thanks for listening
appreciate you
you